Gundrota: that's moving,
and it's gonna do that
in the background
so the app's still responsive.
Watch this.
The boxes in the right
are differentials.
How crazy is that?
Did you ever think you'd see
background processing--
Uh, you'd see
video motion detection
done in JavaScript
in the browser?
You know, I certainly didn't.
This is just fantastic,
and a great demonstration
of these capabilities
all coming together,
and the kind of rich app
that we can now start to build
within the browser.
So I hope you liked that.
[applause]
Let's go back to slides.
Very good.
And once again, that capability,
broadly available
in these modern browsers.
So I hope you've enjoyed
that section of the talk.
That was about
a more powerful web,
and how as an industry we are
creating new capabilities
and, uh, but it's still
up to us as a community
to build the applications
that take advantage
of that more powerful web.
I'm going to pivot
at this point,
and now talk about
making it easier
to build those kind of apps
and how Google Services
can help you.
Obviously if you came to last
year's development conference,
or attended any
of our Google Campfire Ones
or watched them online,
you know that Google's
deeply interested
in making it easier
for you to build web apps.
Two of our offerings
in this space
have been Google App Engine
and Google Web Toolkit.
Google App Engine's value
proposition was very simple.
We said, let us provide
the hosting for your app
so you don't have to worry
about machine instances,
you don't have to worry
about the app's scaling,
you don't have to carry a pager;
we'll do that for you.
And we're gonna give you
an update on that in a moment.
Google Web Toolkit had
a different, uh, proposition.
It said, write in Java,
and we'll compile down,
understand which browser's
being used,
and push down
the appropriate JavaScript,
and do it in a fantastic way
that allows you
to target multiple browsers.
To give you an update
on Google App Engine
and Google Web Toolkit,
let me invite up Andrew Bowers
and Kevin Gibbs.
[applause]
Thank you, guys.
both: Thanks, Vic.
Gibbs: You know, the interest
in adoption that we've seen
in Google App Engine
over the past year
has been truly remarkable.
We've had over 200,000
developers sign up
to use Google App Engine,
and not a single one
of those developers
had to purchase or provision
a server to get started.
They were able to develop
their application locally
on their own machine,
be it Mac, Windows, or Linux,
and leave the servers to us.
Now, our SDK is just
three megabytes.
If you haven't tried out
App Engine before,
I encourage you to download it.
Give it a shot.
Now, since we launched
App Engine last year,
we've also had
over 80,000 applications
deployed on Google App Engine.
Now, often these applications
have been created
by small and agile teams
like many of you
in the audience here,
and they can be because
with App Engine
you don't have to worry
about your configuration,
your up time, or usage spikes,
or re-architecting
your application once it
finally starts to get popular.
In fact, we were able
to put this, uh--
this policy
to the test ourselves
when the White House decided
to use Google Moderator,
which runs on Google App Engine,
for President Obama's
live town hall event.
Despite a traffic peak
of 700 requests per second,
and promotions on all the major
search engines and news sites,
the application scaled
to meet the traffic,
and none of the other
applications were affected.
Now, over the past year
we've also launched
a number of features
and improvement to App Engine,
including things
like our SSL support,
memcache API,
the system status site,
uh, access to secure data
behind the firewall,
and the ability to pay for usage
beyond our free quotas.
Now, we've also found
that there's a number
of additional things
that we'll launch to you
in the coming months.
They include things like
background processing
for your jobs
and large object support
for your application.
If you'd like to learn more,
I'd urge you to come to our
sessions here at Google I/O
over the next two days.
Now, certainly the feature
that we've launched recently
that's generated the most noise
and the most buzz
is our Java language support.
The interest in our Java support
since we launched it
a month and a half ago
has been remarkable.
In a matter of days,
even hours since we launched
our Java support,
we saw developers--many of you
in the audience here today--
dive in and get
not only Java frameworks
working on App Engine,
but also other JVM languages.
Including things
like JRuby, Groovy,
Scala, and even PHP.
And that, we thought,
was truly amazing.
I'd like to say thank you
for all of you early adopters
who gave us a try
and gave us the feedback
with the system.
Now, we found that the demand
for Java on App Engine
has been so overwhelming,
and the response so positive,
we think that we're ready
to take the next step
with Java on App Engine.
So I'd like to announce--
sorry, let's skip this slide.
I'd like to announce
that we are opening sign-ups
for Java on App Engine
as of right now.
Anyone can now log in and create
a Java application immediately.
[applause]
Thank you.
Now with that, I'd like
to stop telling you
about our Java support
in App Engine,
and start showing you.
So I'd like to pull over
Andrew Bowers.
Andrew is gonna
demonstrate to you
how we have an NTN Solution
for creating Java applications
using Google Web Toolkit
and Google App Engine.
Andrew's gonna demonstrate
to you how we think we have
a way to make applications
both more scalable
and easier to use
with back-ends running
on Google App Engine,
and front-ends built
with Google Web Toolkit.
Andrew.
Bowers: Thanks, Kevin.
So if any of you have ever
done Java development,
you've probably experienced
the frustrating lag
between getting a development
environment set up
and actually deploying
something to the web.
And if you're working
on a weekend project,
maybe you decided to go ahead
and use something
like Ruby on Rails 'cause you
wanted to actually
get something out there.
So we definitely recognize
that pain and frustration
in our own lives, and tried
to make the on-ramp to a new app
as quick as possible.
So to demonstrate, I'm going
to create the starter project
from the Eclipse plug-in;
I'm gonna deploy
that to the web.
And I'm gonna use Google
Web Toolkit and App Engine
and hopeful--it should take me
about 2 1/2 minutes,
so somewhere around
there's my goal.
So here I have the Eclipse
development environment.
and let's just get started.
I'm gonna go ahead and open up
the new project wizard.
I'll create something called
"com.google," create a package.
And I'm gonna use Google
Web Toolkit and App Engine.
And this is gonna create
the starter project for me.
Looks like we already
had something running.
We'll go ahead and stop that.
And now I'm gonna start that
on a local server.
So this is a--
Has everything I need already.
I didn't have to install Tomcat,
all I did was I installed
the Google plug-in for Eclipse
into my Eclipse
development environment.
That downloaded
the App Engine SDK,
the Google Web Toolkit SDK,
and the local development server
which mimics
the production environment.
So now I have a, uh,
very simple Ajax application.
It takes some text here.
It synchronously sends that
to the server,
echoes the text back,
as you can see,
and then gives me
a little information
about the server
that I'm running.
Just so we can tell that it's
actually going to the server.
So if we look
at the code for that...
Open up the project here.
You can see I have a client
package and a server package.
Now, all of the code
inside my client package
is Google Web Toolkit code
that's Java code that's going
to be compiled into JavaScript
in the final step.
And it's using--
Uh, it's using widgets
and it's using events
so they're abstracted away so
that it'll work across browsers.
So I could change the text
on the button here to "Post."
Inside my server package
I have Java classes
that are grown as bytecode
on the server
and you can see
that I'm getting RPC,
and I'm echoing it back,
so we'll say,
"Hello from Google I/O."
And we'll save that there.
Now if I go back--
So I've just edited Java code.
I'm gonna go back to my browser,
I'll click "Refresh."
And I see it says "Post,"
and I see it says,
"Hello from Google I/O."
So I just edited Java,
but I'm seeing those changes
now on my browser.
Okay, so I've got
a-a small, functioning app.
Let's go ahead and deploy
that out to the web.
Go back into Eclipse,
I'll go up to the deploy wizard,
and you'll notice there's
an error here right now.
That's 'cause I haven't
set an application ID.
So I'm gonna go
to the App Engine console,
and I'll create
a new application ID.
We'll say, "demoforio."
And we'll save that,
and hope no one
beat me to it out there.
Okay. You're not fast enough.
Great, so we'll go back.
I had some backups just in case.
So we'll set the application ID
here in the environment.
And all I need to do now
is enter in my username
and password.
Then hit the "Deploy" button.
The SDK has taken care
of the rest for me.
So it's going to convert
that Java code
from Google Web Toolkit in the
client package to JavaScript,
it's going to compile the,
uh, Java code to bytecode,
for the server side stuff,
package all of that up
into a web archive directory
and deploy it to the server.
There's no FTP involved by me,
no server configuration;
everything's handled
within the SDK.
And I could do this
from the command line
if I wanted to as well.
And so now we should have
a deployed app.
And hopefully within
a few minutes, here.
So let's go to that
demoforio.appspot.
And so I've got
a fully functioning,
if not very functional,
app out on the web.
[applause]